critter junction has been scaling and
their database model is reaching its
limits
let's look at how we helped critter
junction better serve their users by
doing a bit of re-architecting
building a flexible scalable database
architecture for a large
multiplayer gaming application is no
easy task
the larger a platform is and the more
components that have to interact with
each other the more tech
problems can arise some of the problems
that critter junction had to face for
their flagship multiplayer game
included handling global consistency
importing data
batch processing for analytics and event
streaming
on top of that this system had to handle
access spikes
that after work rush of users logging on
is no joke and downtime
is not an option such a complex problem
couldn't be solved with just
one tool and because critter junction
had already broken their application
into microservices
this allowed them to apply the
appropriate tools to each component
as needed yep that means mixing and
matching google cloud database options
based on questions like what latency is
required
how much persistent data needs to be
supported
does it require offline reporting is the
data structured
or unstructured like we covered last
episode critter junction chose firestore
for their spin-off minigame
but it's also a natural fit for problems
that need a scalable cloud database with
real-time synchronization
and offline support like their flagship
game
and with automatic scaling up to 1
million concurrent connections
and 10 000 writes per second critter
junction doesn't have to lift a finger
or be concerned with downtime regardless
of usage spikes
this means critter junction's
architecture could use firestore for the
game's front-end services like
player authorization and profiles to
store billions of documents with
hierarchical world state data
to take care of the game inventory and
other game elements that need global
consistency like purchase history
critter junction uses spanner as their
main game database
since spanner is a fully managed
relational database that offers
unlimited scalability
strong consistency and five nines
availability
spanner provides a globally consistent
database that can track up to petabytes
of all these important details
without being a choke point in their
architecture spanner supports critter
junction's usage spikes without planning
or
downtime which is a relief for data
admins and users alike
and as you can imagine critter junctions
game access
some data sets more than others
leaderboards and player profiles to name
a few
to prevent lag in the ui and maintain a
quality user experience for this
frequently used data
critter junction went with memory store
a fully managed service that uses redis
to store in-memory data
creating a regional in-memory cache that
speeds up access
that frequently queried data and
improves scale and performance as demand
grows
with memory store for redis critter
junction was able to start small
and increase the size of their instances
without downtime
by monitoring usage traffic and simply
using the gcp console to make
adjustments
for critter junction's huge analytical
workload and time series data that's
where bigtable fits in
it flips scaling on its head and focuses
on connection latency
while traditional nosql databases often
restrict elastic scalability with high
management overhead
bigtable gave critter junction
consistent sub 10 millisecond latency
while scaling to match storage needs
with no downtime during reconfiguration
and because critter junction's game
events were logged into bigtable
their support experts could troubleshoot
problems directly
from there critter junction needed a
sequel friendly solution to analyze
player profile and back-end data
so they used bigquery a highly scalable
server-less multi-cloud data warehouse
bigquery scalability comes from the vast
number of multi-tenant resources
deployed
under the hood allowing them to
instantly allocate large chunks
for seconds at a time while only billing
you for what you use
to keep costs down critter junction
periodically updates bigquery with
front-end
and back-end data which is then run
through data analytics pipelines to
identify gameplay mechanics that need
improvements
so there we have it critter junction
used firestore as a document store for
their front-end services and real-time
game data
spanner for real-time play data and
purchases and memory store to cache
common fetches
then bigtable ingest game event logs
while bigquery helps their analytics
team aggregate data from all those
sources
keep in mind this is just one example of
how to build a heterogeneous storage and
analytics architecture that can span
any industry and while developing a
database architecture that supports tens
of thousands of concurrent players
isn't easy it is possible
so stay tuned to learn how critter
junction continues to improve the design
of their database architecture
for more on this example architecture
check out the description below
and check out our other series on
databases below
and remember always be architecting
[Music]
you